this stuff about ukrainians being nice
is [ __ ] like this is just not true
Putin is a racist
fundamentally my Ukrainian teacher was
under Russian occupation for one month
people said well Terrell how do you feel
walking around the streets you are
obviously you're a foreigner you're like
I said people have no problem with me I
saw a lot of things that my colleagues
in America did not see could you just
imagine waking up trying to call your
parents
call your sister your brother and
they're not answering Russia is like
Iraq it's like Saddam Hussein Ukraine is
Right Russia is wrong
that's just the truth
I am
someone who loves Ukraine I was here at
the beginning of the war and I've been
living in Ukraine for the past 12 years
I first arrived in Ukraine in
2008 only to see if I would like Ukraine
so I was in Georgia in 2008 and that was
when the Russians invaded
uh that country I was taking up Georgian
language class and I was finishing a
requirement for my Master's degrees and
so
I said okay let me go to Keith and see
if I like it and I said okay this place
is cool so I will apply for a Fulbright
and I got the Fulbright Grant and I
arrived in
August of
2009. everybody was in Moscow everybody
had this mindset about looking at
Ukraine and Central Asia through that
lens and I felt like I was beginning to
do something special
and so I felt unique
and and so when I was here covering the
election not covering the election I was
just watching the election between
Victory on the kovitch and type of
Shinko and
and it was interesting listening to taxi
drivers about the differences between
these two people and I was still getting
my Russian together and that was when
uh everybody was focusing on Russian and
now there's this new Renaissance of
learning the Ukrainian language which
I'm a part of but I'm a part of that now
but everybody was taking up Russian and
so sometimes I didn't think I understood
what people were saying to me but one
thing I noticed about that election it
was close
and so the first thing I learned about
Ukraine is even though things weren't
perfect here and that there were a lot
of problems
even in the early days 2008 2009
elections were fairly competitive which
was different from Russia so you
automatically knew that there was a
difference
in these two countries because and
Russia is like Iraq it's like Saddam
Hussein like there is no or Kim Kim
Young Kim Jong-un you know who's going
to win here you didn't
foreign the first uh well the orange
Revolution and then going into my Don
I saw Ukraine's democracy growing and
growing and growing and being here going
on 13 years you just see this growth in
this growth in this growth in this
growth in this growth and
that's what I loved about it but
personally I enjoyed
a number of things the first time I
understood Ukraine from a race
standpoint
was
when this old guy in leviv walked up to
me
I was with a group of Fulbright
students and Scholars
and it was about 20 of us or more
and we were going through the center
and he walked up to me
he walked past all these people and
walked up to me I was the only black
person in the group and he said you know
how you doing you like our city I said
yeah do you speak Russian or Ukraine I
said Ukrainian I mean I'm Russian
and he said do you want to know about
the history of our country
like
who walks up to you and says do you want
to learn about the history of our
country
who does that but this old man who looks
like he's like 80 asked me this question
I said sure and he said you know
these Russians want us to be their
slaves and they want us to be a colony
of Moscow when he just went on and on
and on until one of the Ukrainian
escorts walked up to the guy it was very
polite and then she took me away
but my question was why did this guy
walk up to me of all people and I think
because he felt that I would understand
I've had many experiences like that in
Ukraine and I think it's really
important that you have
people of color diversity because I
honestly believe that we look at this we
look at everything differently because
of our experiences and
that made me want to learn more about
why this old man was drawn to me
and it made me want to understand
Ukraine even more
that has been the way in which I have
done my journalism
and my criticisms and my you know my
commentary about Ukraine
when it deals with the Russia Ukrainian
relationship
I saw a lot of things that my colleagues
in America
did not see
[Music]
so after I finished my Fulbright I went
back to United States stayed for a few
years and then the
invasion of uh 2014 happened because a
lot of people don't remember that this
is the second invasion that happened now
but I was but when this first one
started the first thing I saw where like
all these weird
uh people with the hammer and sickle and
the uh like tanky kind of people
talking about imperialism and Russia is
finding a great old you know imperialist
United States you know all this other
[ __ ]
and
like you know these people's country
were literally invaded and
I joined a group of people online it was
called digital maidan that was fighting
disinformation and that was my first
experience with this information
uh towards Ukraine this is the land of
Nazis and all these other things which
was weird to me because the first thing
I thought about was that I'm like okay
in America my number one job in America
is writing about race and politics
that's what I do I get paid to do that
and I know it very well
and I said you know yeah I did face
racism in Ukraine but here's the thing
I face it in my own country
I could walk down the street in New York
City and get killed by police without a
problem
in the early days of Ukraine all I had
to do was pay Strife to Ukrainian police
and it was okay
they wouldn't shoot me
so that was the game here I didn't die
which I would take that to getting shot
so I'm telling you I know all the you
know the the ways in which you deal with
it here and so I said okay this is this
stuff about ukrainians being nice is
this [ __ ] like this is just not true
so I just started kind of joining people
fighting the disinformation
and I learned that a lot of these people
who are pushing this information in
Ukraine they do it in my own country so
I really learned about that and it gave
me but I just never thought that I would
be learning about all these things
through the perspective of being in
Ukraine and understanding and praying
[Music]
I am an independent journalist
and I am creating ways to diversify my
income and money so before the War I was
here to start a tourism company
yes so before I had one of my best in my
helmet and
ducking Russian missile strikes
I was in Western Ukraine creating a plan
for what what 10 days
in the carpathians look like I would
spend a month in the Carpathian
Mountains and I would go there and my
Ukrainian friends would say oh I've
never been there you know more about
carpathians than I do
and people would say well where where
are you Tyrell I said I am in
I'm about 30 I'm about two hours away
from bukachiva they're like
where's that and I'm in this tiny little
village
and I would be wearing these robes that
were made out of sheep's wool and
they're saying where did you go I said I
went to this tiny little village and I
found it in this you know just you know
old lady was like try this on you look
good in it so how people perceive me in
carpathians I live
in a town called swalliava
I stay about one month there
and I like to run
and so people see me it's kind of like
amazement because
even for ukrainians it's kind of uh not
isolated but not a lot of people know
about it
greetings from the transcarpathian
mountains
Terrell here
y'all see
I'm back in my happy place
here at Ukraine
check out this View
it can't beat it
but I'm just reminding y'all like I do
all the time
take care of your bodies
there's nothing to take care of your
minds don't quit don't give up
again
so just imagine this black dude with the
beard running just cat you know just
running and exercising and they see me
and they're like oh my God and and
sometimes uh the kids will see me and
they run along with me like I'm Rocky or
something many times people would see me
and they would stop me and offer me shot
sleek and beer
and you know they don't give a damn
about I'm trying to stay in shape I'm
literally running and they
they come in the middle row and they
stop me and they come get some shush
leak and some beer and so I have to run
yeah
that has been my experience but now
that is one of the reasons why I'm
learning Ukrainian they they didn't care
that I spoke Russian because you're a
foreigner but it made me learn Ukrainian
that's the first thing but how people in
carpathians responded to me was with
shock in a good way
but a lot of curiosity
um but I would say the carpathians are
definitely my favorite place because
it's this Hideaway beautiful spot that
no one knows about so if I wanted to go
to Paris or Spain or any of these other
places I could do it without a problem
I could go to these places but
that's boring everybody goes to Spain
everybody goes to France
very few people go to the Carpathian
Mountains
[Music]
United States I was building up my
reputation as a political journalist
and I covered my first presidential
election in 2016 and I saw the Russian
disinformation going into my own country
and the same stuff is being pushed about
Ukraine so I saw these parallels
so I said okay I have a area that I
could really dig into like this is my
Lane it's race it's disinformation I'm a
journalist I focus on that and I
developed like a a beat for myself a a
style of writing and journalism and
critique and I started writing for
Washington Post New York Times all these
other Publications
and after 2016 I said you know what I'm
going to make another commitment to come
to Ukraine so I spent my own money
and came here I would stay for two weeks
then the next year I would stay for a
month
then it would be six weeks and two
months and then moved up now to where I
stayed six months of the year and then
that leads up to this year when I was
here in Ukraine when when Russia invaded
for the second time
[Music]
people here like family to me like I
have real close relationships I'm not
talking about I see people on Facebook
or Instagram I know them I spend
holidays with people
and
and so
that's the relationship so when Russia
invaded I didn't want to leave
even though I could have and I was here
and I witnessed so many things in those
first weeks I've witnessed Russian
missile strikes
uh witnessed saboteurs trying to get
through checkpoints I saw a lot of
things that helped ukrainians
um seek Refuge across the borders
so I was and so I was able to document
all that stuff
so I was here as a journalist but I felt
like it was just my small way of
supporting a country that I love and I'm
still here I plan on continuing to
report here because after this war ends
because
you know if we understand history Wars
end
it will end and I'm confident that
Ukraine is going to win and it was one
of the reasons why
I wasn't afraid to stay because everyone
in the west many people were skeptical
that ukrainians will fight back and
that's another thing
I said you don't live here there's a
seething hatred for
for these people a seat and I felt it
and people said well Terrell how do you
feel walking around the streets you are
obviously you're a foreigner you're like
I said people have no problem with me
like I'm fine
because I would take even at the
beginning of the war I was just walking
around with my selfie stick and this is
when things are really tense but people
were not directing any aggression
towards me
there's no chaos and people are actually
pretty polite to one another uh I saw a
guy
um grabbing all of the board show me
water the gas water and he was just just
grabbing them like
and they were finally two left and all
and I looked at him I was like my man
can I please and he was like yeah yeah
you want some yeah so people are pretty
polite here and and
it should be tense but it's not and so
there's just a kindness that people
extend to each other I mean me being the
obvious four in their head
and waving at me so yeah I think they
saw me as somebody that was just trying
to cover what was happening
and
I remember one guy
was he got in front of my camera and he
said only Ukraine will win [ __ ] Russians
he said in perfect English
is that we will kill everybody for our
man
only Ukraine will only Ukraine will win
[ __ ] Russians will kill everybody for
our land
it's our land
okay guys you you see
you see you see what people have to say
about that
all right
because I wasn't I was doing like a
on-demand coverage and I didn't expect
him so I said okay and that got it went
really viral got millions of views but I
was I was confident walking around the
streets because I said the Russians are
not going to take you like they're not
going to do it because these people hate
them that for me was more than reporting
it was just something in my spirit was
saying that I was going to be okay
because these people are going to fight
and that's what keeps me here and that's
what's going to help me to continue to
uh help inform the world about who
Ukraine truly is because I know that
it's it's not anything that Russia and
all these propagandists say that it is
foreign
[Music]
I have done everything in my life to be
what some people would say respectable
I have no criminal record
I go to school
I work for myself no one gives me
anything
I am
here I'm taking this Ukrainian lessons
I'm doing everything to be a global
citizen
but if I walk down the street
in my city in New York and some officer
for whatever reason says I felt
something I'm dead I know this is not
the same example at all
but it's one way that I can help people
relate to what a Ukrainian deals with
and when you're dealing with Russia it's
not just Russians as people you're
dealing with the whole what I call a
Russian supremacist system
in America we call something white
supremacy what ukrainians are dealing
with is a Russian supremacist system
and that's some wording that I've used
it's Russian Supremacy the Russian is at
the top and ukrainians at the bottom
when you listen to Putin's speeches
he talks about ukrainians like their
white trash
thinking about the Crimean tartar's
Islamic terrorists all these things like
Putin is a racist
fundamentally
when you listen to him talk about
ukrainians it's like if I heard him talk
about my country not existing
and you keep hearing that all the time
and all the time and all the time during
the beginning of the war my friends
decided that it would be safer if we
lived together so it's four guys
and two one of them was territorial
defense
and
these people live in Here song that's
where their families are from and every
day they're calling their families
seems they can get through that's what I
saw every day it's simple you wake up in
the morning you get your tea
and
you know Igor is
trying to call
and his mom is not picking up
parents are not picking up
I saw this every day
so I tell people if they want to
understand what could you just imagine
waking up trying to call your parents or
call your sister your brother and
they're not answering and maybe a week
later they'll pick up but they can't
talk long because Russians gave them
their own SIM cards the Russian SIM
cards
and so they have to find some VPN maybe
I find some way to call you so that
maybe their calls are not intercepted
that's a typical life of someone in
Keith who's trying to find their family
or you realize that hey my childhood
friend was killed the shot
my Ukrainian teacher
was under Russian occupation for one
month she was telling me that one of her
family members was just shot dead by a
Russian soldier just blew just shot him
in the head killed him
so those are the stories that you hear
and the question is for what
for what
and it's because they are Ukrainian I
listen to Putin's speech
um
he had a number of announcements leading
up to this war
is either and that's another thing it's
different when you hear them communicate
in Russian in America we get 30 second
Snippets but it's different when you
hear him speak for 13 minutes 20 minutes
and the way that Putin talks about
ukrainians is how the most disgusting
racists talk about black people
so I felt it that way because I know how
it feels to be I know what how hate
feels I'm not the targeted I'm not the
person that Putin was targeting I felt
it
because his hatred was so bad and for
ukrainians
to not want anything to do with Russia I
understand
it's easy for someone who is not touched
by oppression
to think that
returning that hatred
is not a good thing
your parents are not being killed
your families are not being assaulted
sexually you don't have to wake up in
the morning and wonder
how am I going to cook food
where am I going to use the bathroom
because the infrastructure where I live
is destroyed
[Music]
I've been living here for going on 13
years the attitudes that ukrainians have
towards Russia now did not exist when I
first got here
when I first got here
there are a lot of people who are deep
into Russian language there are people
who had no interest in joining NATO
I witnessed from 2009 into 2022 this
change
Russia did that
had nothing to do with ukrainians even
younger people were not so sure about
NATO and the younger people are supposed
to be the ones that are supposed to be
Progressive but even younger people and
that I know where I'm not sure
and so I think that this hatred
when I talk about it is natural in his
response to the actions of Putin not
because who Russians are
and I think that
if we are journalists if we are analysts
we need to step outside of our own
privilege
to take in these feelings
and so when people ask me why would I
you know to describe this in a way that
doesn't make ukrainians have this
anti-ukrainian sentiment
I would say ukrainians are fully
Justified for how they feel
because
I in my own experience can relate to
people who try to oppress me
and if we want to solve that problem
it's the oppressor's responsibility
to change their behavior
you should not blame the victim
for emotionally reacting to someone
treating them like trash
[Music]
heard
many people from different political
views say that
Russia is reacting to American
imperialism via NATO
and
I have a response to that
first I would say that America and
Russia are both imperialist States and
institutions many of my colleagues in
the think tank world
don't agree
I would say that because many of my
colleagues in the think tank world are
white men
who don't understand what it is to deal
with Injustice in the United States
as a political reporter I've covered
elections
and I've seen voter disenfranchisement
I've seen people with whose rights were
stripped from them there were people in
America who are currently alive
who in their younger days had to pay to
vote that exists and if you've lived in
Louisiana
um or if you lived in any other state in
the south in particular you these you
you've run into these people
and they will tell you that we had to
pay poll taxes
so America has its own history
imperialism when you think about South
America when you think about other
places
so when people
identify the United States as an
imperial estate they're telling the
truth
particularly with the Middle East
and and so I would say I agree with you
the challenge is That You Don't See
imperialism anyplace else
okay so that's the issue so we don't
disagree about your analysis about
American imperialism but let's just
start with Russia first of all if I had
a map in front of us I could clearly
tell you that the way that Russia is
created is not indigenous Russian land
just as America
stole land from indigenous communities
so have Russia
do you think those people who have the
Asiatic features are indigenous Russian
people
no how do you think these people became
Russians that's not their ethnicity they
have been colonialized they were
butchered they were killed they were
murdered they make up a Lion's Share
percentage-wise of the people who are
being sent to Ukraine as Canon father
and so when you think about the way of
that Siberia is carved up that is not
indigenous land to Russia if Russia
was true to its indigenous
you know uh makeup
Russia arguably arguably would be half
its size or less Okay so
that's one thing and then two let's look
at the let's look at the the Russian
Empire those countries were not there
because they were they they willfully
wanted to join the Russian Empire they
were they joined by gunpoint the Soviet
Union gunpoints none of these people
wanted to be in the Soviet Union
Ukraine especially did not a lot of
people don't know in the history of
Ukraine there have been you know they
they're a guerrilla uh gorilla fighting
against the state for decades same thing
across other countries other countries
the Soviet Union
in my view and in my language is a
Russian supremacist Empire why do you
think people in these regions speak
Russian
why do you think
much of Africa in the west is speaking
French that's not their language
Francophile countries colonize them
Russia is no different
and if you don't understand this and
these are clearly established facts
then you're being intellectually
dishonest that's just a fact I don't
care what people's politics are I do
care about facts and if you care about
imperialism I would spend less time
thinking about NATO
and think more about why so many Eastern
Europeans want to join if there was no
NATO
much of Eastern Europe Bulgaria Romania
the Baltic states would be in the same
situation that Ukraine is in I think
another issue too is
with people who look at
NATO and United States Sports of support
of Ukraine through this lens of
imperialism so often we look at America
attacking
countries that are made up of people of
color so you think about people in the
Middle East Arabs Persians uh you think
about the case of Afghanistan for
example which Russia also attempted to
colonize and fail along with the United
States you think about South America
these are people of color one of the
fundamental problems with how we analyze
colonialism
in this region is that and this is just
my
um I'm thinking through this but I but I
believe I'm I believe this is true I
think that it's difficult for people to
see for for for people in the west to
see citizens of white skin that's being
oppressed I think people don't have the
same compassion for ukrainians
bulgarians estonians because in our lens
they're white
but in the context of Russian
imperialism and Russian Supremacy they
don't fit the context of white because
they're not Russian
in this region to be Russian is to be
white if you don't have that analysis
you're not going to understand what's
going on here
because they look like all white people
to you
and we've spent so much time thinking
about oppression directed to people of
color that we have not considered
the Ukrainian be it via VIA language via
statehood
um being who they are
right that is another form of in my view
of racism that is another form of
linguistic oppression
and so while I have many disagreements
with these people who I think are kind
of Tankian right-wing Nut Cases
um
I do think that that is one fundamental
problem that they can't see people in
this region as being oppressed and then
also they just simply don't know the
history because when on Twitter
it's very easy for me to break things
down for people because I study it every
day I think that they are invested in
some socialist
um some socialist heaven
or communist heaven
that does not exist
and if they scream something loud enough
it's true to them
even though it's not so my
recommendations for journalists who are
coming to Ukraine to cover this war
eyes it's pretty simple I challenge them
and I challenge myself as well
to decolonize my analysis that means if
you're in Ukraine
you should conduct your journalism in
the way that centers Ukraine
and it should focus on Ukraine seek out
Ukrainian Scholars Ukrainian experts
Ukrainian historians I don't believe in
both sides I honestly believe in many
instances there's somebody who's just
completely right or mostly right and
somebody who's mostly wrong
and we had we cannot be afraid to say
that both sides is a perspective of
privilege
and in my life I don't have the
Privileges of giving my oppressor the
benefit of the doubt
as journalists coming to Ukraine
it is not our right to give the
oppressor the benefit of the doubt this
war is illegal
this annexations are illegal they're
wrong they're committing war crimes
and these soldiers are coming here are
killers they're committing sexual
assaults grapes that's what's happening
Ukraine is Right Russia is wrong that's
just the truth
[Music]
there's a saying in Black American
culture
and we like to say uh we know white
people better than they know themselves
I think ukrainians know Russians better
than they know themselves
and because I come from that background
I listen to ukrainians I never lived in
Moscow
so I don't understand that lens
I lived here
and I see how ukrainians
talk about their experiences with Russia
that is the clear diet perspective
because we're here and we have to Center
those voices for most people
who come from this traditional
background of objectivity that's very
difficult for them but I can tell you
that for people of color it's not
I think that journalists especially the
white ones
they have a harder time with that
because many of them and they don't have
to be bad people
they come from positions of privilege
where they have a choice to sit back and
analyze this person this person is this
person because they are not a victim of
the oppression people who look like me
don't have that luxury
so I automatically am going to Center
Ukraine because my Life Experiences
conditioned me to understand the
oppressed
and that informs my journalism
I think that for journalists who are
coming here
they need to go through the same
self-reflection
that many white journalists had with the
black lives matter movement the
landscape of our journalism in America
changed
because black journalists
demanded that it changed
I think that the analysis of Russia from
a journalism standpoint is changing
because ukrainians
are demanding it for the journalists who
are coming here
they should expect to be challenged
they are often challenged on social
media just as black journalists
and black activists challenge a lot of
white mainstream journalists about the
black lives matter movement
I think that this is a very
healthy environment
so I wouldn't so
in addition to journalists having to
Center Ukraine I would also encourage my
Ukrainian colleagues
to check and make sure that these
journalists are centering you because
from our experience
you're not going to be centered unless
you demand it